[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATHEN HARVEY: Welcome
to "Google Cloud OnAir,"
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars daily, and you
are watching "The Dev
Community," a show where
Google Cloud experts from
the developer community share
perspectives about the Cloud
ecosystem and what's trending.
My name is Nathen Harvey
and I'm a Developer Advocate
with Google Cloud.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Hi,
I'm Nicole Forsgren
and I am the DORA Lead.
And today, we are talking
about the Accelerate 2019
State of DevOps Report.
So let's get started.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah, let's.
So the Accelerate State of
DevOps Report, it's all about,
how do you become an
elite DevOps organization?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Absolutely.
NATHEN HARVEY: So what we're
going to talk about today
is this.
First, DevOps is here to stay.
Next, we'll look at some
of the 2019 benchmarks.
We'll talk about how
to improve, what works
and what doesn't when
it comes to scaling,
and then we'll leave you with
a few takeaways and probably
a reading list.
So first, DevOps.
What is DevOps?
Well, DevOps as a cultural
and technical movement
focused on delivering value
by simultaneously improving
velocity and stability.
DevOps encourages
cross-team collaboration,
shared incentives
and responsibilities,
and an environment that
celebrates learning.
NICOLE FORSGREN: That's
kind of a lot to decompose.
So--
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --there's
a lot to get into.
So don't worry, we're going
to be talking about some
of that today.
The thing that I love
talking about-- when
we say that it's here to
stay, is that it has really
crossed the chasm.
So what we found
this year is we've
really kind of validated
what so many analysts
have been talking about.
For anyone who dug
into the 2018 report,
we found that 17%
of the respondents
were elite performers.
But if you take a look
at this chart here,
that's kind of a subset
of the high performers.
Here's what we found.
That subgroup broke out
into their own group.
It's 20% of our
respondents this year.
So that's pretty
significant, right?
They almost tripled.
It really has crossed the chasm.
We also see 23% of our
group is high performers,
44% now are medium performers,
and 12% are low performers.
Now, for any of you who are
kind of mapping this across,
here's what we see.
As I mentioned, elite
performers have almost tripled.
That high performance
group has pulled across.
Now, medium performers grew.
Where did that growth come from?
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Low
performers shrunk.
So many of them got better,
grew into high performers.
Some of our high performers fell
back into medium performers.
NATHEN HARVEY:
Nicole, why is that?
NICOLE FORSGREN: So we
have a few theories.
In many of the
organizations I've
worked with, what
happens is some of them
are struggling with complexity.
A few of them also
are sitting back.
NATHEN HARVEY: Well, sure.
You said DevOps has
crossed the chasm.
So I've made it.
I'm DevOps now.
Now I can stop.
Ah, that was quite a journey.
But now we've reached
the destination.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Exactly.
And that's not the way
continuous improvement works.
You don't just get to
do a maturity model,
check it off your
box, and be done.
We need to keep
improving, particularly
when we work in things
like technology,
where it's highly complex.
NATHEN HARVEY: Ah.
So this is also interesting.
You mentioned that the elite
performers have broken out.
So help me understand
a little bit more
about, what does that mean from
2018 and as we move into 2019?
NICOLE FORSGREN: I
love that question.
So how do we even measure this?
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Let's talk about this.
So when we talk about
DevOps and performance,
it's important that we're all
speaking the same language.
So when I'm doing research,
it means measurement.
So some of you may have
heard of four key metrics.
This has become an
industry standard.
These are the four key metrics.
We're talking about
speed and stability.
The speed metrics are
deployment frequency--
how often you're pushing code--
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --lead
time for changes--
how long it takes
to go from code
commit to code
running in production.
And then two stability metrics,
time to restore service--
how long it takes
code to come back up--
and change fail rate.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
So first, time to
restore service,
that's when there's an incident
or an outage or something
like that?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Exactly
NATHEN HARVEY: Some sort
of service disruption.
How long does it take
us to get back to that?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
That makes sense.
Then change fail rate.
I mean, I understand each of
those three words on their own,
but putting them
together, I don't
understand what you mean there.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Exactly.
And I'm glad you
asked that question.
So change fail rate--
and by the way,
you can dig into the report.
We have lots of words there.
But basically,
it's the percentage
of changes that fail.
But it's not just
an epic failure.
It's not when your systems
come all the way down.
It's any type of code that
you push into production that
requires any type of attention.
So if it's any type
of instability,
any type of incident,
and it's a percentage.
OK?
NATHEN HARVEY: Gotcha, gotcha.
So it doesn't necessarily mean
that we had to roll it back.
But it does mean that some
human had to take action on that
after the change went--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Exactly.
Exactly.
NATHEN HARVEY: All right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Now, the
really interesting thing,
and the really
important thing to note,
is that, for six years in a
row now, we've seen that speed
and stability, all four of
these metrics, go together.
They move in tandem.
They cluster.
So that picture
that you just saw,
that's actually-- that comes
from a cluster analysis.
So statistically,
all-- technical term--
I take them, all these
four metrics, I throw--
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --them in the
hopper and I see what happens,
how they group.
And we have always seen that
these four grouped together.
In the past, it's been
into three groups.
This year, it fell
into four groups.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Elite
performers-- statistically,
those four grouped together.
And then we have kind of a gap.
And then the four group
together and then we have a gap.
together and a gap.
And that's why we call
them different performance
profiles--
NATHEN HARVEY: I see.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --elite,
high, medium, and low.
So the faster you develop
code, the better stability
is, the higher reliability you
also have, which I think is--
NATHEN HARVEY: Wait, wait.
Nicole, so I get that
clustering here, but--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah?
NATHEN HARVEY: --do you mean
the elite performers are fast?
Or do you mean that the
elite performers are stable?
NICOLE FORSGREN: They're both.
You don't have to sacrifice
speed for stability
or stability for speed.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mm.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Now, here's why.
When we think about this, if
we're pushing code more often,
we are pushing it
in smaller batches--
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --which
means that when our code hits
production, it's smaller.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Let's
think about that in reverse.
If I push code less often--
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
--it batches up.
So I have a bigger
chunk of code.
So I have a bigger chunk
of code hitting production,
which is a larger blast radius.
Which means it has
a higher likelihood
of causing an incident.
And when I do have
an incident, it
takes longer to bring
my code base back up.
And it takes me longer
to fix because it's
harder for me to debug.
NATHEN HARVEY: I see.
So to be more stable,
we have to move faster.
And to be faster, we
have to be more stable.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: And those
things move together.
NICOLE FORSGREN: And
they move together.
NATHEN HARVEY: Oh.
Now, that's really interesting.
But how do you really find
those elite performers
within that cluster?
NICOLE FORSGREN: With
those four numbers.
NATHEN HARVEY: I see.
NICOLE FORSGREN: And I do
that statistically with--
it's math.
NATHEN HARVEY: Math.
NICOLE FORSGREN: That cluster
analysis, math and stats.
Now, what does that
look like, though?
So often people
want to take a look
and understand where they are.
So this is our benchmark.
And as I mentioned,
elite performers
are optimizing on
all four measures.
So we can see the
elite performers
are pushing code multiple
times a day or on demand.
The lead time for changes
is less than a day.
They can get that code all
the way through the pipeline.
Time to restore service
is less than an hour.
And change fail rate
is between 0% and 15%.
It's usually closer to
2% to 3% to 4% to 5%.
NATHEN HARVEY: Hm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Now, low
performers, in contrast.
The deployment frequency is
between once per month and once
every six months.
Lead time for changes is between
one month and six months.
Time to restore service is
between one week and one month.
And that change fail rate-- take
a look-- between 46% and 60%.
NATHEN HARVEY: So that's
about half the time
I have to intervene
after I've pushed
a change out into production.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So
think about that.
So much of your time is
spent debugging your own code
in production,
putting out fires.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
Is that usually planned for?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Probably not.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So think
about value creation.
Whether it's in
features or building
out new infrastructure--
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --this
is the value of DevOps.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
And when you talk
about deployment
frequency, and
especially looking
at that elite performers, you
say multiple deploys per day.
So what if I'm not doing
multiple deploys per day?
Does that mean I can't
be an elite performer?
NICOLE FORSGREN: So what it
means is you probably aren't.
And we should be
pushing towards that.
Now, it does say on demand
and multiple deploys per day.
On demand is important
there, because it's
the difference
between a business
decision and a
technical constraint.
So if you can, but
you're just not,
we do see some
differences between--
in retail, you may push
to a pre-prod environment,
but you aren't
necessarily pushing
to an app in the app store,
because no users want
to be refreshing their
apps every single hour.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right, right.
OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: But again,
it's a business decision and not
a technical constraint.
NATHEN HARVEY: I see.
Gotcha.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
And it's important,
because it's not
just for features.
It can be for compliance
and regulatory changes.
It could be for patches.
It can be for security.
It enables so many things.
NATHEN HARVEY: Nice.
NICOLE FORSGREN: OK.
Let's move on.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: There's
so much to cover.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
So what are these
numbers actually look
like when we put
them all together?
NICOLE FORSGREN: When
we put them together
and when we compare, we see that
our highest performers, when
we compare to our
lowest performers,
see 208 times more
frequent code deployments,
106 times faster lead time
from commit to deploy.
Now, what does that enable?
Like I said, it's
not just features.
It's stability.
It's reliability.
It's security.
So it's over 2,600 times
faster recovery from incidents.
NATHEN HARVEY: Wow.
NICOLE FORSGREN: It
enables stability.
It's seven times lower
change fail rate.
NATHEN HARVEY: I
mean, these numbers
are almost hard to believe.
NICOLE FORSGREN: I know, right?
But we've seen it several
years in a row now.
NATHEN HARVEY: How long has
this report been running?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Six.
NATHEN HARVEY: This
is the sixth year?
NICOLE FORSGREN: This
is the sixth year now.
NATHEN HARVEY: And
the numbers, it
sounds like they're probably
improving over time,
but they lay out
essentially the same.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
Exactly.
NATHEN HARVEY:
That's incredible.
Now, it's great that
you can recover fast
and that your change
file rate is low
and you're deploying fast,
but what about availability?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Availability
is super important.
And I'm glad you brought
this up because there
is this saying that I love
that, day one is short
and day two is long.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mm.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
And for those of you
unfamiliar with it, it's
that we can build code,
we can make code, we can make
software relatively quickly.
But we need to maintain it for
a really, really long time.
And that's what
availability gets at.
It's about the assertions
and the promises
that we make and keep
to our customers.
And so availability
is important.
We started researching
and measuring
availability and its
impacts last year in 2018.
We measured it again this year
and found that, no surprise,
it's really important.
And it's important for
a couple of reasons.
In part, it helps us predict
organizational performance
better than software
delivery alone.
Now, organizational
performance is
important from a
commercial standpoint
and a non-commercial standpoint.
Everyone's like, Nicole, what?
Girl.
That's my academic hat on.
Commercial are things like
productivity, revenue, right?
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Non-commercial are
things like effectiveness
and efficiency and customer
satisfaction.
So it just comes back
to delivering value.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK, great.
So how do we think
about availability?
This was a good question.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
This is a great question.
And availability is, again,
about that long tail.
And so I'd really
like to point people
to Google's SRE practices.
NATHEN HARVEY: Oh,
and this is something
that I definitely know about.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yes.
NATHEN HARVEY: So Google's
SRE practices can really
help define availability.
And the thing that I love
about the SRE practices
when we talk about
them is it always
starts with the customer.
So we're really thinking about,
what does the customer journey
look like?
What is the customer expecting?
Availability-- if your server is
running but your customer can't
complete the task
that they wanted,
is your service
really available?
Probably not.
So it all comes down to that
customer-oriented focus.
We want to understand,
what are our customers are
trying to do with our services?
And to that end, the
SRE practices also
introduce these three different
dynamics or dimensions
that you can look at.
The service level indicators,
service level objectives,
and service level
agreements or SLAs.
So let's just walk through them.
And I'm going to sort
of countdown in reverse.
So we'll go 3, 2, 1.
We're going to start with
service level indicators.
So a service level
indicator is an indicator
that your service
gives that says, hey,
are your customers happy
or are your customers sad?
It's a good way to sort of
measure uptime, availability,
latency, things like this.
Things that matter to customers.
And then an objective, a
service level objective,
is a goal that we set
around that metric.
So we want to make sure that
we're available n-percent
of the time.
Maybe that's 99.9% of the time.
And maybe our latency--
are services responding
fast when we expect it to?
And then a service
level agreement kind of
goes a step beyond that.
Now, a service level
agreement is typically
an arrangement that is
made between businesses.
And so when you miss your
service level agreement,
there are usually consequences.
Those consequences usually
are a refund to your customer.
And I don't really know
what business you're in,
but I bet it's not giving
your customers money.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Probably not.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
Probably not.
We want to take the
money from the customers.
I mean, we want to earn
that money, obviously.
NICOLE FORSGREN: And we want
to make our customers happy.
NATHEN HARVEY:
Absolutely, and so when
we look at service level
objectives and service level
indicators, it's really about
what makes that customer happy.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Absolutely.
OK.
Now, this is some fun stats.
This is some stats nerd time.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah?
NICOLE FORSGREN: But I
love this because it's
really, really interesting from
a practitioner point of view.
From an executive point of view.
From an industry point of view.
So this year, we ran
additional analysis-- well,
for the last few years, we've
run additional analysis.
And for years, we found the
industry doesn't matter.
If anyone's ever heard
me talk, I always
say industry doesn't matter.
Guess what?
For the first time,
industry matters.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
So first, industry
doesn't matter.
Now, industry does matter.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Now,
industry matters.
NATHEN HARVEY: And so what you
mean as that industry can help
us understand if
this organization is
going to be an elite
performer or a low performer?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Or if
industry may have an impact.
NATHEN HARVEY: I see.
OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So for
an example, for years,
people have always said, oh,
but I'm highly regulated.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Right?
And I've always said, eh.
NATHEN HARVEY: Doesn't matter.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Don't make excuses.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mm, OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: I
mean, I love you.
Also, don't make excuses.
So we capture industry
for a dozen industries.
This is just kind of a
representative sample.
NATHEN HARVEY: Uh-huh.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
What we have found--
NATHEN HARVEY: Let me guess.
Let me guess.
My guess is that the
technology organizations,
because they're
they're going to be
the elite performers.
They're going to be the
ones that really stand out.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Everyone, no.
NATHEN HARVEY: What?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Retail.
And retail does
significantly better.
Now, we lay this
out in the report--
I love your shocked face.
This is my favorite.
Now, what we found is that,
for the last decade or so,
there's been what has been
termed the retail apocalypse.
NATHEN HARVEY: Oh, yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: It is
unbelievably competitive.
Retailers have had
to embrace things
like A/B testing to
really understand
what drives consumer behavior--
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --so that they
know what to offer consumers.
They've had unbelievably
slim margin,
so they have to
embrace efficiency.
They have to embrace automation.
They also have to do
things like scaling
for things like Black Friday.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So there
is no question about,
should we go to the cloud?
Should we embrace automation?
Should we be doing
things like A/B testing?
They are already there.
Because if they don't, they
have already closed down.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
And with Google Cloud, we see
eBay doing things like this.
So they're using
machine learning models
and they're using
artificial intelligence
to really help their customers
find exactly what they're
looking for much faster.
Making that a much more
efficient transaction,
both from the
customer perspective
and from eBay's perspective.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
And so we caution that very many
other industries are probably
following suit pretty quickly.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
That's nice.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
So another thing
that we found is that
heavyweight process,
heavyweight controls,
heavyweight change approval
boards--
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
--only slow you down.
NATHEN HARVEY:
They slow us down.
NICOLE FORSGREN: And,
as we've mentioned,
when you are slowed
down, that leads
to batching up of work,
which leads to instability.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
So a heavyweight
process and control
over the changes that go in,
that's there for stability.
NICOLE FORSGREN: It is.
NATHEN HARVEY: It's there
to help us and protect us.
NICOLE FORSGREN: We have
the best of intentions.
But that can lead to
unintended consequences.
And in 2014, we studied
this for the first time.
And we found that
heavyweight change approvals
were negatively
correlated with stability.
And so, this year, we took
a more rigorous approach.
I wanted to really
design this in.
And what we find
is it negatively
predicts speed and stability
for the same reason
I talked about before.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: When
you batch up changes,
you have a larger blast radius.
So it causes instability.
NATHEN HARVEY: But so, in my
organization, I'm an architect.
And I have a good eye--
I can see the entire landscape
and I understand how changes
are coming at the system.
And I have a better purview
to decide whether or not
this is a safe change.
So how does that slow us down?
NICOLE FORSGREN:
So my favorite joke
is, when I submit code
review of 10 lines of code,
someone will approve-- well,
they will find 10 errors.
But when I submit 1,000
lines of code, it looks good.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So the
only thing that happens
is it ends up introducing delay.
However, we do have this great
section showing what the CAB--
change approval board--
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
--what the CAB will
look like in the continuous
delivery paradigm.
And what it ends up looking like
are strategists and information
beacons.
And what you can end up doing
instead is architecting--
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --and
not just being approvers.
NATHEN HARVEY: Got it.
Got it.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So there's
a lot of good stuff in there.
NATHEN HARVEY: Oh,
that's awesome.
All right.
So we understand a little
bit about elite performers
and what slows us down.
How do we get better?
NICOLE FORSGREN: There's
so much to do here.
OK.
This year-- I'm so excited.
I got a little excited.
We have two models.
So in the past, we've taken
a look at performance.
I've been talking a little
bit about software delivery
performance, speed
and stability,
organizational performance.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: We did
that again this year
and added some new stuff
like we have in the past.
We also took a look
at productivity.
So we have two models.
NATHEN HARVEY: Two
different research models.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Two
different research models
that are predictive.
So--
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
--keep that in mind.
I'll show you two models.
We're going to hustle through.
NATHEN HARVEY: Two predictive
research mod-- whoa.
NICOLE FORSGREN: I know.
NATHEN HARVEY: What is
going on here, Nicole?
NICOLE FORSGREN: OK.
I'm going to teach you all
how to read a research model.
These are my favorite.
OK.
Anytime you see a box,
this is a construct.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So
a construct helps
us understand what a thing is.
I'm going to call it a thing.
It's a construct.
And it ends up
helping us understand
how to measure something,
how to evaluate something,
in ways that only
measure the thing.
NATHEN HARVEY: Uh-huh.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Don't
measure anything else.
And that everyone reads
pretty much the same way.
Now, I said the word,
thing, a bunch there.
So let's look at
something like monitoring.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yes.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So monitoring.
Monitoring is a box.
Monitoring is a construct.
So when we measure monitoring in
a scientifically, academically
rigorous way, I know that it's
comprised of a few things.
Monitoring across application,
across infrastructure,
and it's used to make
business decisions.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
When you include
monitoring that
way, that helps you
is the entire stack, in
order for it to be predictive
of continuous-- of improving
continuous delivery,
it needs to capture
all of those things.
And if you word the questions
in just the right way, that's
the monitoring construct.
And it measures monitoring.
And those questions don't
capture anything else.
They don't capture loosely
coupled architecture.
They don't capture
trunk-based development.
And everyone who
reads the survey
reads all of those questions
about the same way.
NATHEN HARVEY: Gotcha.
So the question is
asked in such a way
that I know you're asking
me about monitoring
and I understand what you
mean when you say monitoring.
And I know that's not about
trunk-based development.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
And there are several questions.
There are lots of them.
So I make sure that if
you misunderstand it--
so we ask lots of questions.
By the way, I love all of
you who took the survey.
That's why there are
so many questions.
Because then, on the
off-chance that I
made a mistake or the
team made a mistake,
and we wrote a question
that wasn't clear,
I can catch it when I do
my stats-fu and we toss it.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
So we've got these
boxes, the constructs--
NICOLE FORSGREN:
We've got these boxes.
NATHEN HARVEY: --and then
I see a bunch of arrows.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Now we have arrows.
Now, the errors are predictive.
So this goes beyond
just correlation.
We have prediction.
So when time asset
monitoring is predictive
of continuous
delivery, once I know
I have the boxes
identified, the constructs,
I can look at the
relationship between and among
the constructs.
So I know the types
of things that
are predictive of continuous
delivery, that helped me
with continuous delivery.
I know the things
that are predictive
of SDO, software delivery
and operational performance.
Now, occasionally, you
will also see a line
with an arrow with
a minus next to it.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So
you'll see that--
NATHEN HARVEY: I see one.
Continuous delivery to burnout.
So continuous delivery
is predictive of burnout.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Of
reducing burnout.
NATHEN HARVEY: Ah, that's
what the minus is for.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yes.
NATHEN HARVEY: Gotcha.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So any time you
see an arrow without the minus,
you can read it as
drives, impacts, predicts.
If it's a minus, it negatively
impacts or it reduces.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
Gotcha.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So that's
how we can read the model.
And you will notice that oval.
That's our control--
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --variable.
That's how I found out
that industry like retail
was different.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: We also see
enterprise is different--
NATHEN HARVEY:
Enterprise is different?
NICOLE FORSGREN: --this year,
for the first time only,
the size of the company.
NATHEN HARVEY: The
size of the company
is different or leads
to different results.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Leads
to different results
in a significant way.
NATHEN HARVEY: Interesting.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So now that
we know how to read it--
NATHEN HARVEY: All right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --there's
lots more in the report.
NATHEN HARVEY: Let's
drill in a little bit.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Let's
drill into something.
Where do we want to start?
Ooh.
NATHEN HARVEY: Cloud.
So cloud is a differentiator
for elite performance.
OK.
Now, Nicole, you said that
when you ask a question,
I understand what you
mean by the question--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY: --and you're
only asking about that thing--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah, yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY: --that construct.
OK.
So cloud.
NICOLE FORSGREN: See--
NATHEN HARVEY: Cloud?
NICOLE FORSGREN: See, you're
making a face, though.
And I get it, because I go to--
I talk to lots people.
I talk to a lot of developers.
I talk to a lot of sysadmins.
I talk to lots of executives.
And you can ask five people
what they mean by cloud,
and I'm going to
get like 13 answers.
NATHEN HARVEY: Sure.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Because it's the cloud.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
So what do you mean?
NICOLE FORSGREN: So how
do I get around this?
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: I get
around this by asking about,
how do you define
cloud as defined
by NIST, National Institute
of Standards and Technology?
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
So how does NIST define cloud?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Five
key capabilities.
On-demand self-service--
NATHEN HARVEY: Wait a minute.
Is this public cloud
or private cloud?
NICOLE FORSGREN:
It doesn't matter.
It's how you architect it.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
All right.
So you said on-demand
self-service was the first one.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
On-demand self-service.
NATHEN HARVEY: All right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Can't put
it behind a ticket that
requires human intervention.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
So if I need a
resource, let's say
a compute instance,
I, the developer,
can provision that on my own--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: --without
having to open up a ticket,
hand it off to
another department,
wait for that to be
processed, and then come back
and now I have a VM.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Zero points.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: [LAUGH]
NATHEN HARVEY:
The next one I see
here is broad network access.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: All right.
Tell me what that means.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Can you access it
from lots of different
types of devices?
NATHEN HARVEY: I see.
So if I'm on-call and I
need to restore an incident,
and I happen to be at dinner,
can I do that from my phone?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: Interesting.
OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Resource pooling.
NATHEN HARVEY: Resource pooling.
NICOLE FORSGREN: I'm
sure you know this one.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah, of course.
So I have-- the provider,
the cloud provider,
has a bunch of resources
and they pool them up,
and then I use what I want,
and then I give it back
and whatever.
And it's just there for me.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Rapid elasticity.
Bursting like magic.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yes.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
This is my favorite.
NATHEN HARVEY: Up,
up, up, up, up, up.
That's the beauty of the cloud.
We can scale as
our customers-- we
get more and more
customers coming in,
our infrastructure just grows.
We serve all of those requests.
Everyone goes home happy.
Right?
NICOLE FORSGREN: And down.
NATHEN HARVEY: Oh, right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Up and down.
NATHEN HARVEY: And down.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yes.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yes.
Elastic.
It goes both ways.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yes.
NATHEN HARVEY: That's an--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yes
NATHEN HARVEY: --important
thing to remember.
I've seen many,
many people that are
newer to cloud that are excited
about the up capabilities,
or scale out capabilities--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY:
--and kind of forget
that the idea is also
to scale it back down.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
Well--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Which
relates to measured service.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
So we want to measure,
how much are we
actually using the cloud?
And we can get way
different insights
into how we're
utilizing a service.
And, importantly, what my CFO
cares about, how much money
am I spending on a service?
That's a completely different--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
And we only pay for what we use.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Absolutely.
So this is what defines cloud.
So-- but, listen, cloud's
been around for a long time.
So basically every--
I mean, shouldn't it
just be a control?
Obviously, everyone's
doing cloud.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
In theory, right?
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: The
challenge, though, like I said,
is that everyone
defines it differently.
So that's why this
research is so important.
Because when I go
talk to organizations,
when I go talk to people leading
transformations, they're like,
but we did the cloud.
I'm not getting benefits.
Why doesn't it work?
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So we
asked, who's in the cloud?
And then we asked
these five questions.
Turns out, only
29% of respondents
who said they're
using a cloud actually
meet all five characteristics
of cloud computing.
So if you're in an
organization that says,
we're doing the cloud.
It's not working for me.
I'm not getting thing--
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --this
is the disconnect.
So it requires execution.
I mean, I bought--
I mean, I paid for a
membership to my gym,
but I don't have a five
mile-- a five minute mile yet.
NATHEN HARVEY: I paid for a
membership to the gym also.
NICOLE FORSGREN: [LAUGH]
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: You
have to do the work.
I'm not saying it's
necessarily simple.
It requires work.
It requires automation.
It requires architecting things.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: But
you've got to do them both.
You've got to do them both.
NATHEN HARVEY: And
investment, it sounds like.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: So--
OK.
So clearly there's room
to grow with cloud.
But how does this
line up across--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Why do we care?
NATHEN HARVEY: --elite
performers, low performers,
what does that show?
NICOLE FORSGREN: It enables
and accelerates this.
Elite performers
are 24 times more
likely to have met all
cloud characteristics.
NATHEN HARVEY: Wow.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Right?
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Because
it's about enabling.
It's about accelerating.
It's about speeding things up.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: It really
helps so many things go.
OK.
We've got some clear wins here.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
It's clear that we need
to get to the cloud--
and really think about the
cloud as the whole thing.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY: So we have
this idea of fast autoscaling.
And as we talked about,
that's elasticity.
So that's scaling up--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY: --scaling down.
And the important thing there,
I think, in addition to fast
is autoscaling.
So--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yes.
NATHEN HARVEY: --it doesn't
require human intervention
or opening up a ticket.
Hey, I need to scale
up because we're
about to have a bunch
of customers come in.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
Exactly.
NATHEN HARVEY: Next, we
talked about cost visibility.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
The cost visibility
is really interesting.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So we do have
a section in the report showing
that because of the way
the cloud is architected,
and because of the information
it makes available,
it brings that
visibility back to those
who are building systems.
Now, when we're on-prem, it's
just kind of a black box.
And so there is no incentive
to change the way that we're
engineering our systems.
If we want to aggressively make
our systems more efficient,
why?
And we can't.
The cloud enables us to do that,
in terms of compute resources
or cycles.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right, right.
Interesting.
And then you also mentioned
security here as a clear win
from cloud.
I know a lot of
people, as they're just
getting into the cloud, and
certainly in some industries,
there's some hesitance about
going to the cloud because
of security.
So how is security a clear
win from the cloud, Nicole?
NICOLE FORSGREN: So there
are so many cloud providers
that have already gone through
so many steps and so many hoops
to be a secure system that
meet so many compliance
regulations from
information security
to even physical security.
But then you no
longer have to worry
about-- you can
allow your engineers
and your professionals to focus
on building code the right way,
and not have to worry
about securing your system
and securing your
buildings, even.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right, right.
Well, that's great.
And, of course,
Google Cloud has a ton
of different
services for you that
are available to allow
your engineers to focus
on building out the applications
that your customers care about.
It turns out, your
customers don't actually
care about the infrastructure
on which your applications run.
What they care about is
that that infrastructure
is available.
Sure, they care about that.
But they don't even care really
about the infrastructure.
It's about the applications.
So Google Cloud offers a
number of different resources
that allow you to focus
exclusively on that application
and put some of those
infrastructure concerns
to the side, or
at least decrease
your investment in those
infrastructure concerns.
So we have tools for
compute, for machine learning
and artificial intelligence,
messaging, monitoring,
learning-- all of these things
are built in to the Cloud
itself.
And when we look
at the Cloud, we
see a number of
different capabilities
that are really awesome.
One of them that I'm
super excited about right
now is this function or
feature called Cloud Run.
Cloud Run is this idea where
we can take serverless agility
and use that with our
containerized applications.
So what does that actually mean?
It means that our developers can
have a true serverless workflow
and serverless approach
to the applications
that they're building.
You take your application,
you containerize it,
and then you hand
it to Cloud Run.
That's it.
You don't have to worry about
your infrastructure at all.
Cloud Run will scale up as
your users use your service
or as your demand requires.
Cloud Run will also scale
all the way down to zero.
And one of my favorite parts
about it, and my CFO's,
is you only pay for when
the requests are actually
being processed.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Nice.
NATHEN HARVEY: Now,
that's really cool.
It's also a great example of
something else that we've seen.
We're seeing lots of
organizations, for example,
at the Broad Institute, they're
cutting the cost of research
by adopting more and more
of the Cloud features.
So maybe they started off
with just compute instances.
And, over time, as
they start really
looking at the capabilities
that Google Cloud provides,
they're able to really
slash the cost of research.
So they go from maybe just
a compute instance down
to some task splitting, some
pre-emptable VMs, and so forth,
all the way through to the
point where they're now
using algorithms to tune how
they're utilizing resources
on Google Cloud platform.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So I love that,
because that's a great example
of aligning incentives.
Once you provide the
cloud to your developers,
they can really tease
apart only what they need.
They can build their
algorithms, their applications
to really be super efficient
and just use what they need.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
The other thing I
love about it is how
it took an iterative approach.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: Let's
get this into the cloud.
And now that it's in cloud, we
can start thinking about, how
do we take more
advantage of the features
that the cloud really
has to offer for us?
NICOLE FORSGREN: I love it.
And I love it because
it's the Broad Institute
and they're doing research.
NATHEN HARVEY: Absolutely.
And the other thing that we talk
about a lot is shifting left.
So what does it mean
to shift left, Nicole?
Can you talk about that?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
Shifting left is integrating
features and functions earlier
into the tool chain.
And earlier into the process.
Because if we find it late--
late in the system,
late in the game--
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --it's so
hard and it's so expensive.
And by expensive,
I just mean effort
to integrate all those changes.
The earlier we can find, the
earlier in the feedback cycle--
NATHEN HARVEY: Right
NICOLE FORSGREN: --the
better we can deal with it.
And the higher the quality is.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
And so we've learned about that.
When it comes to
building applications,
we all know that fixing
a bug in production
is much more expensive than
fixing a bug during design.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Right.
And in the 2018 report, we
found that elite performers
could find security features
in days and fix them in days.
Where the low performance,
it took them weeks to find.
And then weeks again
to remediate them.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
So when security
is an afterthought,
when we think
about security when
we get into production, that
it's already too late, right?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY: So when we
talk about shifting left
on security, we're
really talking
about taking those
security concerns
and moving them to the
left side of our workflow.
We're back to the code, the
build portion of that workflow.
And, in fact, using
Google Cloud, when
you take your application and
build it into a container,
we have vulnerability scanning
that can look at that container
and tell you
whether or not there
are security vulnerabilities,
known vulnerabilities,
before your container, before
your code gets anywhere
near production.
We can really improve
that feedback cycle
and get it earlier
in the process.
And so if there's a
vulnerability found,
we'll stop you there.
And then the other thing that
we have is binary authorization.
So you've packaged up your
application into a container,
you're ready to
take that container
and run it in your GKE cluster
or run it on Kubernetes.
Well, how do you know that
that container that you're
about to run is actually the
container that you expect?
Is it an approved container
that you're going to run?
And so that's what binary
authorization can do for us.
It will look at the
binaries and say, yes,
this is an approved
binary or, no,
this cannot go to production.
And we see this with tremendous
success over at Shopify.
So every day, 6,000
built container images
are deployed securely into
Shopify's environment.
6,000 container images.
And there are
actually over 3,300--
sorry, 330,000 images stored in
Shopify's Container Registry.
NICOLE FORSGREN: And I
love that because it shows
how security can be scalable.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yes.
Absolutely.
And when we shift
it to the left,
it makes it all
that more scalable.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
Exactly.
Now-- OK, let's dig
into a few more.
The thing that's
important here-- so
think about a holistic
approach to CD.
Because it is technology.
It is tooling.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yes.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
It's also process.
So when we take a
look here, we can
see how all of these things,
clear change process,
disaster recovery testing,
continuous delivering
in this automation, really
drives our speed, stability,
and availability.
One thing that's
important here is,
we think about useful,
integrated, easy-to-use tools
it helps makes CI/CD accessible.
Now, on a personal note, I
love this, because some of this
reaches all the way back to my
dissertation and my postdoc.
NATHEN HARVEY: Nice.
Well, when you think about the
integrated experience-- look,
I'm a developer.
I want to stay in the same
context throughout my day.
And it doesn't matter if I'm
writing code for the first time
or getting that code
pushed off to production.
And so with things
like Cloud Build, which
is integrated with GitHub, you
can actually get those signals
all without leaving the
UI and the experience
that you're used to.
So within GitHub itself,
when I submit a change,
Cloud Build can
pick up that change
and automatically build it.
I don't have to switch
contexts and think,
OK, I've submitted a change, now
I need to go build the thing.
The thing gets built.
And I get feedback
directly in that same
interface that tells me,
how did that build go?
Were there vulnerabilities
in that build?
And so forth.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
Now, what we found is only
40% of our respondents
are doing disaster
recovery testing annually.
NATHEN HARVEY: Annually?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Annually.
NATHEN HARVEY: Annually.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Disaster recovery testing
is pretty important
because it helps
us understand the state
our production systems
and what's necessary,
important to keep them running.
So I love the idea of these
DiRT events-- disaster recovery
testing.
And before I ever
came to Google,
I kept hearing stories about it.
So much so that we included
this quote from Kripa Krishnan
in the book.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah,
it's a great quote.
For DiRT-style events
to be successful,
an organization first needs
to accept system and process
failures as a means of learning.
Things will go wrong.
When they do, the focus needs
to be on fixing the error
instead of reprimanding
an individual
or team for a failure
of complex systems.
I love that.
The whole focus on
learning is something that
really brings joy to my heart.
NICOLE FORSGREN: I
know, it's great.
And the thing that
I love about this
is that focus is not
just on improving
the technology, but also
the team surrounding it
and the processes
surrounding it.
Because there's so
much opportunity
to make things better here.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yes.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Now,
I'm excited about this.
Because in the past,
Google's Project Aristotle
has studied this culture
of psychological safety
and how it's so important for
teams to be able to do this.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Now, there was
a little bit of side commentary
out in the industry saying, of
course, Google would find this.
Because Google is
this environment where
you have this amazing
culture, and you
don't have to
worry about things,
and they give you
lunch, and everyone
passes this amazingly
difficult bar for interview.
And there's no way
that this could
hold in the rest of the world.
And so many thanks to the
Project Aristotle team.
They shared their
measurement instrument
with the DORA research
team this year.
And so we studied
this externally.
And this is what we found.
We found that this same culture
of openness and shared purpose
also contributes to software
development, delivery.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So
it's a slightly--
it's a different
outcome, but similar.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: In
the rest of the world,
these same findings hold true.
NATHEN HARVEY: I see.
And culture is more
than just free lunch.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Absolutely.
NATHEN HARVEY: So let's talk
about some of the culture
that we do have a Google
that I think can apply
in your organization as well.
So the first is that
we let data guide us.
We use data to make decisions.
That's super important.
Next, we have collaboration
and a shared fate.
So when you think
about DevOps, how
do we align development
and operations?
We're collaborating together.
We're sharing a fate or we're
sharing responsibilities.
Next, there's transparency.
So we talked about this a lot
when we talked about Cloud.
Can you get transparency
into what is the resource?
What are the
resources costing you?
How are those
resources performing?
And so forth.
That transparency is
important within our systems.
But when I say systems,
I mean our systems.
Not just our systems,
but our systems, right?
So think about CPU, of course.
But finances and
customer satisfaction.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: Transparency is
important across all of that.
And then, lastly, and
every organization
can take on this as
part of their culture,
a blameless post-mortem culture.
Where when incidents happen,
and they will happen, what we do
is we take those incidents and
those failures as opportunities
to learn.
And we do that through a good
blameless post-mortem culture.
NICOLE FORSGREN: OK.
Now, let's dig into the
second research model.
As I said before,
any time there's
a box, that's a construct.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Any
time there's an arrow,
you can read it as a prediction.
If that error has a minus,
it means it reduces.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: So this year,
we took a look at productivity.
Now, this is a special
kind of productivity.
It's not writing lines of code.
It's not the number
of bugs that you kill.
It's when you hit that
special flow, when
you feel like you've done
a lot of good, complex work
for the day.
Now, productivity is
important because it
helps us feel like
we've accomplished work.
It helps us do a lot of
good work for the day.
Now, what types of things do
we feel I contribute to this?
We just talked about
useful easy-to-use tools.
This is great because it's
highly correlated to the CI/CD
work that we just talked about.
Also search.
Also things like
reducing technical debt.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: We're going
to dig into a couple of these.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
So it's--
NICOLE FORSGREN: I just
talked about search.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
Let's start with search.
So I see here that
we have a 1.73 times
productivity improvement when
there's good internal search.
What you mean by
internal search?
NICOLE FORSGREN: So internal
search encompasses a lot
of things.
It's like, can I search
my internal code base?
Do I have a good internal
set of documentation?
Do I have knowledge bases?
Do I have wikis?
Can I-- do I feel like
I can ask my colleagues?
NATHEN HARVEY: Hm.
OK.
NICOLE FORSGREN: It
encompasses a few things.
NATHEN HARVEY: Got you.
And then external search might
be things like Stack Overflow
or YouTube videos,
for that matter,
places where developers and
operators go to learn more
about the technology
that they're using,
or the tools that they're using,
maybe the bug that they've
encountered--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
NATHEN HARVEY: --they use
external search for that.
NICOLE FORSGREN: One note
that's important to point out
here is that external
search is going
to be better if you're
using open source tools,
because there will be a broad
community from which you
can pull.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
For sure.
And who isn't using open source?
NICOLE FORSGREN: I will say that
low performers are the highest
users of a fully
proprietary toolset.
NATHEN HARVEY: Oh.
NICOLE FORSGREN: But
read into it more.
We don't have time
to get into it now.
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah, definitely.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Teaser.
OK.
Also technical debt drives
reductions in productivity.
So how can we reduce
technical debt?
This is super important.
And we see the shops
so many places.
One thing that's interesting--
because we all know
that refactoring
helps with technical debt.
Martin Fowler wrote
a great book on it.
But what else can we do in
terms of smart investments
in tooling?
Code maintainability?
How can we maintain our code?
Help our code
bases be searchable
so that we don't contribute
to tough dependencies?
Loosely coupled architecture
helps with this, as well as
monitoring.
One thing that's interesting,
you'll probably note,
these things also show up
in our other research model.
Smart investments in flexible,
extensible viewable systems
help reduce technical debt.
NATHEN HARVEY: So this
can help with performance
and productivity.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Absolutely.
NATHEN HARVEY: Great.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Now, what else?
Why do we care?
I mean, I want to be productive.
The other reason
this is important
is that, when I have
a good day at work,
when I feel like I hit
that great information,
that great flow--
NATHEN HARVEY: Yeah.
NICOLE FORSGREN: --and
I can get a lot done,
I can solve complex
problems, that
lets me leave work at work.
I can shut my head off.
I can shut my brain off.
I can go home and it
helps reduce burnout.
NATHEN HARVEY: Oh, that's great.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yeah.
So next up, quickly, what
works and what doesn't.
So many people
ask me, how can we
scale my DevOps transformation?
NATHEN HARVEY: For sure.
I mean, we've been talking about
the word DevOps for a decade
now.
NICOLE FORSGREN: I know.
NATHEN HARVEY: And
I've seen organizations
where a small pocket
of the organization
will adopt some of these
practices and ideas,
and they do so to great success.
But how do they get that to go
across the entire organization?
How do you actually
scale it out?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Right.
So we asked all
of our respondents
what they're doing,
what they were seeing.
And then we did an additional
analysis, another cluster
analysis, particularly among
our high and elite performers,
which was over 40%
of our population.
So you can choose what
works best for you.
Here's what we see.
Elite teams favor structural
solutions that build community.
Things like communities of
practice, grassroots efforts,
and a couple proof of concepts.
The reasons these are good is
because they build communities
so they will be robust to things
like reorgs or product changes.
NATHEN HARVEY: OK.
So if these are the
things that are good,
what are the things
that we should avoid?
NICOLE FORSGREN: These
things are not great--
training centers,
centers of excellence,
or a big bang approach.
Now, there were a
couple notable training
centers that have gotten some
press that are pretty good.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mhm.
NICOLE FORSGREN: The
challenge of some of these,
and centers of
excellence, are that it
centers expertise in one place.
It essentially
creates another silo.
They also take
extensive resources.
It's really, really
tough to figure out
how to get that to spread
throughout an organization
and keep it sustainable.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: It can work.
But you've got to know
what you're in for.
NATHEN HARVEY: Well, and I would
suspect that a training center
works best when the learners
that come into that training
center come in with a problem
of their own to solve--
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
NATHEN HARVEY: --as
opposed to come in
to consume some
predefined curriculum.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
Now, we do see it show up in a
handful of our high performers.
But only about 9%.
NATHEN HARVEY: Mm.
NICOLE FORSGREN:
Now, I will mention
big bang approach doesn't
show up among our highest
performers really at all.
We do see it among
our low performers,
which does make sense.
If you need a hard
reset, you can do it.
But you need to
know that this needs
to be a multi-year approach
and a multi-year model.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
NICOLE FORSGREN: OK.
Some of our key takeaways.
The industry continues
to approve, particularly
among our highest performers.
NATHEN HARVEY: All right.
Well, that's great.
So if the industry
continues to improve--
and we talked earlier about
DevOps cross the chasm.
Can we just stop
talking about DevOps?
NICOLE FORSGREN: [LAUGH]
NATHEN HARVEY: Is
it now just the way?
NICOLE FORSGREN: It could be.
And honestly, so many companies
I work with ask me that.
I would say, choose
the word that resonates
for you and your organization.
If it's DevOps, if it's agile,
if it's digital transformation,
if it's just
transformation, use whatever
is going to work for you.
NATHEN HARVEY: And
that's going to help you
with both your commercial and
your non-commercial goals.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
Absolutely.
Cloud continues to
be a differentiator
for the elite performers.
But, remember, you
have to do it right.
NATHEN HARVEY: Right.
So make those investments
in those five key areas that
define, what does it mean to
actually be using the cloud?
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
Productivity can drive
performance and work/life
balance and reduce burnout.
NATHEN HARVEY: Which
is super important.
NICOLE FORSGREN: For sure.
NATHEN HARVEY: And also the
bottom-up or grassroots,
along with communities
of practice,
work well for scaling out
your DevOps transformation.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Yep.
Now, remember,
download the report
for so many more
findings and details.
You can find that at
cloud.google.com/devops.
NATHEN HARVEY: That's
the 2019 Accelerate
State of DevOps Report.
All right.
Well, thank you so much
for tuning in today.
Please visit "Cloud OnAir" for
more content from Google Cloud
experts.
Bye-bye.
NICOLE FORSGREN: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]